half Americans don't want
atheist in-laws an atheist in their family this
is really nuts
I have a feeling Jaclyns gonna have a little something to say about this a Pew Research
Center poll asked americans
whether they would be disappointed if a
close family member married someone
a different race a different country
different political party
or someone who doesn't believe in God
the scariest a ball bearings
but the new study findings 49 percent of
Americans said they would be
disappointed if their family member
married EDS hatch people I cannot
believe that seventy-three percent of
conservatives said they would be less
than thrilled
if a family member married neediest and
nearly a quarter of Americans who call
themselves consistently liberal and
forty-one percent of mostly liberal
respondents so they wouldn't want
atheist to marry into their family so I
that's the 1i want to start with
a quarter a liberals I mean we're
supposed to be the ones that are
forward-thinking
and open to other ideas and one out of
four liberals
does not want you in their family
jacqueline glendon
go I am I'm I'm so horrible Batman
I think it just comes along with a
misconception ATS have no morals
that we're not that people I mean none
of those numbers surprise me because
I've been around for a long time I know
how distressing really like the most
distrusted group of people
yeah in this country there's many
studies that say that people I meet you
I mean there there was a study one time
when they ask people and there's an
abandoned car and it was
you know for me with your install
everything out it would you expect that
this person was
you know ABC in 10 options like you know
rapist a murderer atheist in the Bicol
definitely the apts that with the
highest shows an answer and it's like
really I mean whenever it all these
different studies are lined up we are on
par
with rapists and murderers yeah as far
as you know the lack of trust goes
and its it's fascinating I think most
that's because it's such a stigma behind
it because people think that you have to
have religion to have morality her
some sort spirituality in to say that
you know your on your own about that is
is very scary to a lot of people yet so
quick before a job in hague so how old
dozen ABS get morals if not being handed
down to him by the Lord everyone has
morals and if you follow the morals
handed down to you by the Lord end up in
jail
yeah rail a lot I for an idea that they
had me
yeah and I'll kill your kids and staff
in this action up happening now
or people with the faith healing sup
they're not getting their kids a medical
term that they need an
you know whenever they're obviously you
repeat offenders convey what one kid I
then another kid dies then they go to
jail you know the first one okay
yeah but I mean if it's happening now
people are following you know
the word in the Bible and that's
happening yeah so
so what do you make a the the quarter
the liberals because that's the number
here the judge the conservative thing I
get naked your
more conservative in your more religious
then I can understand this I don't agree
with it but I can understand it
the corner we will that a lot I'd like
to see how they broke down the word
liberal because the bill doesn't
necessarily mean not religious cellular
so a lot of liberals
actually are dues to identify with some
kind of a man I think people in general
its human you wanna see yourself
reflected in
and others and those the ones you
gravity told more towards anyways
because America is such a I would say
it's pure
has such a strong spiritual foundation
that
it just seems into everyone's way of
life in so when they run into someone
who completely rejects
all and that and we're and we're talking
not just christianity which i think is
probably the most prevalent
religions here but when they're likely
mean you don't even
believe in Oprah an energy than the
univer-
and Lake any and all day like that sweet
like why
who did this to you know him love you i
cant even you like to make you turn out
somewhere yeah
but I mean I think another thing about
this is like whenever you think about
the word liberal
a lot of times when we identify
something you expect everyone in that
you know category is like this awesome
mean open minded free thinking person
here and I've learned the hard way that
even within the atheist community you
can expect all them to be open-minded
and free-thinking interject there is
discrimination in with me
and getting a because you're human being
and you know just because you're a
liberal or conservative for an atheist
or Christian or whatever
I mean it there are still those human
tendency is that make certain people
horrible I mean you can be a bad person
an atheist your question I whatever you
know
yes there's bad people everywhere health
how much is the guys name has to do with
tradition
more than religion per se because I
could see
I'm not religious per se but I do like
some of the traditions like during
Passover I'll have the same here I like
the traditional bit
it doesn't have a religious connotation
to me really
so I could see why someone would say oh
I don't want someone coming into my
family he's not gonna care
about the the traditions more than the
religion
itself my bit jumpers something and I
can see that yeah
I can see that being anything but I
think most of it is just people are
scared me yes yeah I mean even if you
sat there in fact I'm not religious
that would go over completely different
things than a gift
right now like I've heard stories people
you know saying that they're not
religious or
they're not a Pearson and the responses
like an understanding of believing in
God and He
and a like did anything eraser lemme
like nihilistic something like they may
have no belief system whatsoever is that
well I mean maybe but that's just a
misconception when is your personal
definition how
why do you label yourself in eight years
I don't believe in God a fact that it
like that all and yeah he's looking
hashana
will be good I
might not have gathered or did you think
we need more
atheists to come out of the closet I
i've talked about this a couple times
we've done this before that
you know even somebody like Barney Frank
who was
wife open network say he was openly gay
in the
eighties in congress I think you can
like 92 93
had an incredible we proficient career
and then he didn't come how as an EDS
until about a month after
he resigned last year so
atheists are actually behind gay people
in the in there
burning exposure not the past year when
you're trying to say game is then
80 s rights are the new trans rights is
what your chance we
worry I won't raise people are just
getting their rights but there's not
even time for that I'm sorry I really
put I know
yeah he just deal with one thing at a
time exactly I
eat answer question yes I think it's
very important because I do i do believe
that
atheists are misrepresented and
misunderstood in this country
your I assume that you think maury is
needed as someone that publicly is %um
is all the time yeah I mean there's such
a stake my life like the only way to get
rid of that is too
you know say hey I'm a normal have been
nice person and I'm an atheist
%um
up